Russell thanks for letting us in your
house man well thanks thanks for coming
here not many people do really oh that's
why they have Studio it's just our faces
listen thank you so much for coming on
the show it's a real pleasure um I went
to school with a bunch of guys from Hong
Kong so I saw your stuff from like way
back when because it was so popular and
it's interesting because all your comedy
was always based around race and
ethnicity and all that sort of stuff and
the world has evolved over time right
how do you see the landscape of comedy
and all that stuff nowadays well I Al
Whatever is taboo is kind of more the
fun stuff to talk about you know and you
got to you want to bring it up just to
hear the reaction you don't even have to
have a joke ready sometimes you just be
like and then blah blah blah and they're
like o and then you go okay I'll do
something now you know it's your job is
to ruffle feathers right M it's
interesting you say that I think most
comedians of my generation and younger
would would shy away from that why is it
that your generation saw it as ruffling
feathers and mine and younger would say
no you you don't want to ruffle feathers
you want to be sensitive yeah no we're
not about being sensitive but you know
the truth we we're we're supposed to
tell the truth that's our jobs right
we're we're the last truth tellers and
Truth is like poetry and nobody likes
[__]
poetry well said so uh I know a lots of
people obviously you're very successful
and very famous now but I'm curious to
kind of like how did you get here what's
been the journey through life because
you were in the UK scene for a while and
like tell us your story a little bit so
I started in 1989
I think I was a year out of high school
at that time I didn't really have any
plans I was I was DJing that's how I was
making my money I would DJ at clubs on
weekends and then uh what kind of DJ
were you uh um everything I play back
then you had to play everything you
could not you could not just be I only
play this kind of guy cuz you had to buy
records back then and if you were only
going to buy like House Records you're
going to you're going to have to really
work hard to get to that position um so
you'd buy it everything I buy I
personally I was playing hip-hop and R&B
um but then I'd also buy house then I'd
have to buy pop records because if
you're playing a party people are going
to want to hear this is the realm of the
night I'm like I don't want to BU play
that record or buy that record but it's
going to make you money you got to do it
ding Queen did you buy that hell yeah I
had that left over from the 70s so
that's a very English thing yeah it if
you go to a nightclub you're going to
hear Dancing Queen and you're going to
hear some Tom Jones and uh and some of
the old classics from the 70s which I
really
appreciate so you were you a DJ how did
that get into doing standup comedy I was
boxing as well I was just amateur at the
time but um I was like well this is
never going to work out I'm not I boxed
but I wasn't a fighter you know what I
mean like that's how I always broke it
down when I'd go to the gym there were
guys that were Fighters and then there
was guys like me who would go and train
and we didn't have a problem getting in
the ring and sparring with you and
getting beat up a little bit but I
wasn't going to get up at 5:00 a.m. and
go running they' be like you want to
come run running at 5:00 a.m. I'm like
I'll see you at 3:30 in the afternoon
for some good oldfashioned jump rope you
know so and then so you would doing that
and then so how did you get into standup
did you do in the traditional way was
yuck yucks a thing back then I started
at yuck Yu it was um what the hell is
yucky Yu it's the comedy chain of comedy
clubs in Canada they the they used to be
the largest chain of comedy clubs in the
world yeah okay and uh so what happened
was the summer of ' 89 I was working at
like Wendy's mhm I was a shift manager
and then I got fired for not firing
somebody like we need you to fire that
guy I go why I go come on man that's not
a reason to fire him if you don't fire
him we fire you I go I guess you're
firing me because I'm not firing that
guy I think I was too compassionate for
that job yeah and then my dad kept
asking what are you going to do you're
not in school anymore you're not working
what are you going to do what are you
going to do and my brother who's 6 years
older than me I was like what are you
gonna do and then he like what are you
interested and I go I don't know and
then one of my cousins I we write a
family party and I said some funny
things my cousin Andrew goes you're
funny man you should do standup and I
was like it's interesting nobody in my
family's ever complimented me
ever throughout boxing throughout DJing
throughout break dancing nobody
complimented me for anything then my
cousin Andrew was like you should do
standup and I was
like that's interesting and because I
always listen to standup I've always
been a fan of
standup I uh I've been listening to it
since the 70s so it wasn't like I didn't
understand what standup was but I'd
never actually seen it live I saw it in
1986 1986 I saw Eddie Murphy in Toronto
doing the raw tour wow but it was called
pieces of my mind at the time when he
was touring it was called pieces of my
mind and when he recorded it and
released it was called raw because I
remember going to the theater to see it
and going this the same concert I just
saw and but I was like oh my God there's
things missing I saw things that
nobody's going to know you know um so I
and I was a big Carlin fan already and
chich and Chong and Steve Martin and all
that stuff so I was listening to Comedy
a
lot so I was like told my brother go
Andrew said I should do stand up I try
standup he goes have you ever seen
standup and I go I seen Eddie Mur goes
have you ever seen real standup like
guys that are in the trenches and I go
no so he took me to uh like this theater
Sports it was like a improv show class
thing and I was like no that's not it
and then he took me to yuck yucks to see
amateur night and I was like that's it
that's what I want to do and he goes
okay well figure out how to do it and I
go all right so I ask somebody how do
you get on they tell me how to call the
number and at 9:00 a.m. on this day and
put your name in and then you'll you'll
get a you'll call back and you'll check
the voicemail to see if you're on so I
did and that's how I got my first spot
and I was terrible as everybody is one
they I hate when guys say that oh oh
they dared me to come on so I came on
and I killed and the club offered me a
weekend I'm like that doesn't [__]
work like that this is the real life
this is real life I don't know where
this movie world you're living in is did
you have material or do you did you just
go up there and think oh I'm just going
to do five minutes off the top of my
head and I'll be no I wasn't that
arrogant thank goodness but I uh but I
was naive enough to not realize when you
first get on stage and hear yourself on
a mic you're like oh boy this is I'm the
only one in the room I'm the only thing
you can hear in this room and there's no
outside noise maybe a place clanking
here and there but that's about it you
don't hear nothing and and audience is
just staring at you and waiting and I
was like it's very different than being
the funny guy with your friends where
you're sitting around there's background
noises you know somebody talking there's
a phone ringing all these things you
don't pay attention to because you're
just focused on each other but when
you're on stage for the first time you
notice every single sound in the room I
think I had five minutes and I did three
and a half maybe it was terrible did you
bum oh no funny enough I mean I probably
did but I remember it differently yeah
and then they offered you a weekend yeah
and then then I started headlining doing
Arenas a week later
so so when I did Wembley in ' 89 I
um so you didn't quite bomb you got some
laughs right I got a chuckle or two yeah
and I was like oh I like that I got to
figure I got to figure out how to get
more of that and I came back again the
week
later and I got more Chuckles and but I
did less time I think I did two and a
half that night I got the chuckles I was
like oh that's great bye good night I
was like I like you have two and a half
left I go that's good that's good I got
the laugh right I just wanted to get the
laugh and then I started doing it more
and more often till you know you start
to figure it out you do the amateur
circuit and people are like hey I got a
I got a room out in Bowmanville on
Tuesday nights and they there's no money
but they uh pay you in chicken wings and
free sodas and and they'll they have a
go-kart track and they let us drive
around the go-kart track I'm 19 I'm like
hell yeah that's
amazing and then so you so you then went
onto the circuit professionally in
Canada you were earning money what made
you want to go to the UK well I was on
the circuit in Canada um I just started
getting on the circuit you got
understand I started in ' 89 there was
guys coming in like after me and moving
up and moving on past me and I was like
what the [__] is going on and I remember
in 93 I think I entered this comedy
competition and um I had the best set of
the night but I
lost I remember the three guys that beat
me I go how the [__] did they beat me
they were all terrible not terrible but
I'm like and then they were like I go
how did I lose they go you did somebody
else's joke on stage and I was like what
the [__] which joke and they told me
which joke and I a friend of mine was
like yo you know what's really funny
this show and blah blah blah then you
you talk about that and I go oh that's
good yeah and I took his advice and I
took that joke and that's how I lost
that competition I was like [__]
I remember it was 93 they're giving away
a cell phone I was like a cell phone
this
amazing I remember the three Comics it
was Matthew boand he won he was from
monreal and and uh and uh Ian serota he
came in second and Jack Norman came in
third and I was like [__] and
I'm I think he won that one I think I
won I think I played the uh long game I
played the long game so uh what was your
first like in every career there's a big
there are some big breaks what was your
first one where you were like oh okay
this is real now okay so
95 I did my first special I six years in
there was a a show called comics in
Canada uh CBC produced it and they
um they would take like I think eight
comics and they'd give you a 30 minute
special but half so it was 22 really and
uh you'd have to do half standup half
sketch wow yeah so I did sketch sketches
and they were the sketches were bumpers
before the commercials so I did did that
and then when it aired they suddenly got
flooded with like fan mail like who is
this guy where going we see him girls
were sending photos of themselves and I
was like this is awesome what's going on
right now and then they had people
calling in telling them they're going to
they're going to boycott the CBC if they
ever play me again and stuff like that
so it was like it was like this whole
thing that happened in Canada and some
some like Indian newspaper out of
Vancouver the guy was like if you I'm
going to get the whole Indian Community
this is he's like the guy they're like
CBC calls me in and I'm like I'm
thinking I'm in
trouble they're like you got we got got
we got this letter from this guy in
newspaper in British Columbia who says
he's going to get people to boycott the
CBC and I'm like [__] this is it's over
for me and he goes you know how good
this
is you know what that means you're
making waves kid and I'm like what
really and uh what was the next show
that complaints he's racist he's not
they didn't know I was Indian because of
my name and I was making jokes about
Indian names and and then I did a joke
about a uh an all Indian ice hockey team
I said the Toronto Maple
seeks and then like I but I had like
some troubles after that like I remember
I was at a club one night and uh these
three big Indian dudes came surrounded
me at this pushing up against the wall
surrounded me it was two one here one
here one in front of me and they're like
we don't like the jokes you're making
and you don't disrespect and I'm like
the GU poking me in a I just went pop
pop pop and I just got the [__] out of
there I hit all three of them and I ran
out of the [__] club really so even
back then are you being serious yeah
yeah yeah you you beat up three Indian
dudes three dudes like I was surrounded
I had no choice I didn't do that they
going to beat [__] out of me it's at
that point you go go for it you really
do you do have that what what do they
call internalized Brown phobia whatever
it is it's uh no it's fight or flight it
was they three of they had me surrounded
like this and and they were bigger guys
and I I was like I was like uh okay I'm
going to hit this guy then this guy then
this guy and I'm out of here but I don't
because your stuff isn't offensive
Russell was it no but back then because
when were the when you're the first guy
yeah there was nobody before me there
was no Indian guy before me yeah so it
was Zero representation and now all of a
sudden there's this young Indian kid 25
26 years old who's out there saying all
these wacky things and doing the accent
and his act and all that and they when
you're the first one people are fearful
of you because they're like wait what if
he misrepresents us what if he gets them
to hate us more you know we don't we
didn't know what it was it was the 90s
as well so um I understood like why like
I understood you know you know
retroactively obviously understand but
um at the time I didn't get I was like
what did I do wrong you know you know
once you you know but hindsight
obviously so you know I I understand
their fear or understood their fears of
what they thought was going to you know
what what could possibly go wrong and
that's why you knocked them out that's
right well I did I totally understand
you I did that for my own safety I went
right up the middle and I got doing them
Boop and Boop so accents is a funny one
because you're kind of known for doing
every accent like I mentioned my friends
from Hong Kong you do that accent and
now you know I think it's fair to say
people are way more sensitive about
stuff like that like what do you make of
of of how you know how that that
situation is do you think we should be
able to do any accent or do you think
some accents are of limits or no I think
I don't think it's about limits are off
limits I think if it's done in in the
right context it's okay like if I'm like
you know I talking to a Chinese guy and
he's like yeah so there I was at the
mall I'm like do you see do you picture
a Chinese person right now no you have
to go into something that makes you if
I'm trying to tell you a story I need to
take you to the place and if I'm not
going to if I'm just going to draw an
outline and not color it in then I'm not
really going to give you much of a story
you need the details and the details the
devils and the details but it's
interesting that you say that because
because there would be lots of people so
for instance if I told a story that
about an Indian cab driver for instance
and I did the accent in a club I would
automatically be called
racist well again it depends on depends
on how accurate your accent is really
yeah there's a there's do your best
Indian accent do it okay so I'll tell
the story so I was in is this one of
your bits actually yeah no no no this is
a true story it always makes me laugh
because I was getting a cab from the
station to the Manchester Comedy Store
and this Indian gave me a lift and we
started talking and I'm a fan of history
and he he was talking with me and he
said to me do not thing whatever you
bloody British go you [__] things up and
that Mak laugh yeah no that wouldn't
work because you know what
happens I realized where you went
wrong the accent well that and then but
you're like when I do an accent I kind
of my face my body changes to a that
person it's almost like a character
actor I guess I mean I'm not that deep
in that [__] but you know like when I do
it it's it you're you have to change
every part about you cuz you're not
going to move the same way yeah so you
know I'm not going to be like then I was
you have your head automatically has
just you
know depends on how close you are to
these people you're going to have to pay
attention you know Chinese it's all it
was always you know uh so don't say
nothing bad [__] there those
movements are sudden you know what I
mean so it always has to everything has
to and your face you see the face
changes and stuff that's I think that's
how and why I got away with doing what I
did because they knew I wasn't doing it
to mock them I was literally doing it to
contextualize the story I was telling
well all my Chinese and Hong kongese
friends absolutely loved it like that's
how I find out about your standup is
from the people whose accent you were
doing right and that you know what I get
now is a lot of Russians coming out to
see me because of the bit I did about
Russians about the Russians speaking
back you I don't care yeah they speak
very offensive yes absolutely should be
can absolutely and I threw real Russian
words in it when I did it you know you
speak Russian yeah I was throwing in you
know little swear words that they would
use that's you got to do something like
that for those for that group so they
don't think you're mocking them they
know adid and he said something I hold
on he knows something you want to make
him go if he took the time out to learn
that I don't think he's mocking us yeah
he gets us yeah get us little it's about
being seen I want to make sure people
are seen and I think that's what my
generation Comics do um oh hello
[Laughter]
Piper have you trained your pug to do
anything inappropriate um my wife
has
put I got the full depth of that joke
over time yeah um but it's interesting
that you say that because you it got to
a point are you're distracted by the dog
yeah distract yeah I'm distracted by the
joke right U but you
go he's having a breakdown I am having a
breakdown but it came to a point I
noticed round about sort of
2019 where MC's in a club almost avoided
like if there was a black person or an
Asian person in the audience because
they didn't want to be seen to be racist
and they wouldn't take the piss out of
them and I'm like that's the most racist
thing that you can do because actually
to take the piss out of them in British
culture it's that's a sign of love
that's what I say yeah that's exactly
what I say I said that's how you our
love language is insults yeah like if
you can walk up somebody he you CT and
then like oh how you doing mate oh yeah
no he gets it and I get it now we're
cool I know that this guy's not going to
be a dick if I say something to him now
so you do well in Canada yeah and how
did you end up in the UK well so I was I
was so I did the special in '95 and then
in
90 in uh was it the summer of 95 Junior
Simpson came to
Toronto on a vacation with his then
girlfriend and he just happened to pop
around like yuck yucks and I happened to
meet him and I was like hey what do you
know com from London oh cool yeah I just
want to see the scene you want to get on
and I got him on and I took him around
to a bunch of different clubs and I got
him on in all these different clubs and
he goes hey if you ever want to come to
England I can probably try and get you
on there too so I flew to England that
September and he got me on I think the
first uh first ging was in Reading
somewhere
jungers reading no it wasn't even
junglers there was like a it was a black
show that we did and they had never seen
an Indian guy speak Jamaican
before well they had his name was Apache
Indian but but he doesn't count no so
they hadn't seen like this Indian guy iy
spoke perfect Jamaican they were like
how the [__] how did and I started
killing the black rooms in England and
then uh joh fun AR they oh yeah they
were the best back in the day they were
so fun and then John keys I got
connected you know John Keys No I don't
know he was Paramount management or
Paramount he he had the same name as
Paramount funny enough but but he was uh
he was an agent out of London who took
me on and started booking me everywhere
nice and so you did the London circuit
and you you must have gigged at the same
time kind of as Eddie isard and all
those types of people Eddie I remember
in 96 I did a TV show me and Mitch
Hedberg did a wow live at junglers when
they did that series live at jungers in
'96 and Rick Wakeman from yes was
hosting it was it from the prog rock
band Yes yes he was hosting and I did a
joke that the audience didn't get it go
you know Rick just so you know in India
your group's name is
hunie but it was way ahead of its
time we'll be back with Russell in a
minute but first we've got a message for
the gentleman of our audience from our
sponsors manscaped the folks over at
manscaped have been working night and
day to bring you a below the waist
grooming experience like none other with
their brand new performance package 5.0
Ultra we've been working with manscape
for 2 years now and if like me you're a
young man about town and I am young shut
it and you want to impress the ladies or
gents then I recommend you take a look
at manscape to level up your grooming
game and boost your confidence and
there's no better way to start than with
their brand new performance package 5
Zero Ultra inside the package you'll
find the best trimmer on the market the
lawn mower 5.0 Ultra this is manscaped
fifth generation trimmer and features
two interchangeable skin safe blade
heads there's a standard head for taking
a little off the top and a new foil
blade for you to go smooth wherever your
heart desires also inside this package
you get the weed whacker 2.0 ear and
nose hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant crop Soo toner and that's not
it you also get the the incredibly
comfortable manscape boxes 2.0 plus
their newest travel bag get 20% off and
free shipping with the code trigger2 at
manscape.com that's 20% off plus free
shipping with the code trigger2 at
manscape.com
manscaped trim your chesticles with the
besticles they made me say
that so you you were gigging with all
these guys and was Patrice cuz he was in
the UK at that time wasn't he Patrice
was um Patrice didn't start coming over
really till late '90s early 2000s when
uh I was already sleeping on patrice's
couch in '96 though in Woodbridge New
Jersey when it was Patrice and Keith
Robinson and then in 2000 when I did
Edinburgh uh I was doing my shows but
Patrice was out there with uh Rich boss
and LS schaer oh yeah L schaer not gay
big shout out to L yeah we love L um and
what was Patrice like we asked this
question of everybody Patrice was
[__] brutally hilarious but he wanted
to hurt your feelings and if your
feelings didn't get hurt he'd get mad
like he would try to hurt my feelings
all the time but I I I was S I thought
he was so brilliant that I would always
laugh because I was a fan of his you
know I mean and we were friends I
remember in
2005 four or five we were in Vegas um
doing this Comedy Fest and we're
standing backstage and i' already
started getting a little heat now and
we're standing there patri goes slaps
him on the arm yo I'm not saying you're
not funny
but you're not funny enough to be
getting all the [__] you're getting I go
I
agree I go it could have been you but
just not you man and he would get mad if
you didn't if I laughed when he made
like hurt he' get what the [__] is wrong
with you I'm like trying to hurt your
feelings I'm like you can't I'm a fan
what made you a fan of his just his
honesty him and Keith Robinson changed
the way I do comedy in 96 cuz I had that
special Comics that I was telling you
about and and I brought it to New York
with me on
VHS I said hey you guys want to see my
new special like yeah so I put it on and
uh they watch it and at the end I go
well and they go what the [__] was that
I what are you talking about they go
that was the worst piece of [__] I've
ever seen in my life and I go come on
you're kidding what no we're not kidding
go that [__] was popular in Canada got
nominated for an award that's [__]
that's why Canada sucks I was like Wow
and then then they broke down why the
special wasn't funny and why wasn't it
funny
what's so different about any of those
jokes what what what makes those jokes
so special that somebody else can't do
them what what is what what is you in
those jokes and they really made me
start to think about yeah somebody could
steal your jokes if if somebody can
steal your joke that means it's not
really your joke because uh it's just
it's it's a good joke but they were a
bit generic is yeah I guess that's what
they were trying to get there's nothing
personalized about these and then I
started working on getting more
insightful yeah and then because that's
what Patrice was he was very insightful
when he talked about men versus women or
you know these subjects under most
comedians would be dismissed as hack he
he ended up giving a unique Insight he
would give yeah he was very insightful
and he was very uh um articulate he
would articulate exactly what he was
trying to say with it and he didn't have
a problem with that and and he wasn't
afraid of how it came across and he
wasn't afraid of bombing either because
he used to bomb no you think he used to
like bombing too but you know he's 6' 6
6'5 6'6 you're not going to you're not
going to intimidate a guy like that did
bur ever tell you about how Patrice got
into comedy
no um Bill blooming R Bill Bloom told me
this because Bill used to own the comedy
Connection in Boston he said Patrice was
a door man there and uh I think Burr was
doing a set this like in the maybe 90 91
maybe I think Burr was maybe still open
mic or whatever at the time but you know
he was doing well and uh Patrice goes up
to Burr and goes
yo how do you do this like how do you
how do you do this [__] goes what do you
mean he goes you want to try it he goes
yeah I could do it [__] better than
you I was like wow I can do this better
than you like that's that's [__]
Patrice in a nutshell you know yeah yeah
and
so he never really got the praise that
he deserved he died right as it was
about to happen but there was a
self-destructive element to it wasn't
there uh to a certain degree I mean he
knew what vices were and his weaknesses
were and he didn't really pay much
attention to it and he just and the
vices and weaknesses were food I take it
yeah food and yeah he didn't I don't
think he smoked or nothing he didn't do
anything wild he wasn't a drinker and he
just yeah just a big guy and he had
diabetes and he had a stroke and that
did him in and so you were carrying on
within the British circuit and when was
the moment that you decided that you
needed to go bigger you needed to go to
America it wasn't that I decided
anything okay I was just happy going to
London and basing out of London because
You' go so from 95 to 2002 I was based
out of London so to speak because I
would do like I'd go three weeks London
two weeks Toronto three weeks London two
weeks Toronto and I would just keep
going back and forth so that I was I
didn't want to saturate One Market more
than the other and and then there's so
many different gigs that would come up
out of England you would get you would
get Dublin you would get you would get
uh uh Belfast then you would get
Edinburgh you would get uh uh um you get
Belgium you'd get then I got Dubai I got
Hong Kong I got Singapore I got all
these places I never even [__] knew
existed and I was like this is amazing
and you know they're flying you out
economy putting you up in the best three
star hotels you can get
you but you know after staying in hotels
in England you realize that all these
Asian hotels are so much better you know
when you're staying at I forgot the name
of those a chain of them they're [__]
hotels in England Travel Lodge they're
yeah I guess they're Travel Lodge there
was one of those types of things where
and then you stay in bnbs and you're
like this is before airbnbs these are
actual bnbs and then the I remember
staying at a B&B in Dairy in Dairy wow
and the lady was like if you come back
after 11: I'm not going to let you in
but I got to work I came back and I had
to sleep out that night cuz the lady
wouldn't let me back in the house really
so what made you come to America then
well I did so let me let me give you the
details here so you understand that 95
did a special um then that was received
so well that they gave me another
special in 97 but that was too soon for
me cuz I wasn't that good at writing yet
I wasn't that prolific I didn't have the
foresight I didn't understand so they
gave me the second special 97 which was
kind of eh that one was called show me
the funny and if you watch it you'll
still be waiting for me to show you that
funny and then and they gave so they
gave me 10 grand for that special in '97
which was the time was a lot of money
for me I like holy [__] 10 grand this is
awesome and then I got a holding deal
for 10 grand so I made 20 grand off
comedy in that little period I was like
and so I bought a
leis
uh bought Lexus and uh and that was a it
was a it was a it was a gift and a curse
I remember hanging out with Dave
Chappelle around 96 997 right after I
bought this 97 after I bought the car
and then I remember I was struggling to
make the payment on it and he was
shooting Half Bake and I was like [__]
Dave I'm I was kind of hinting hoping
he'd offer the offer me a payment I was
like [__] man I got this car payment I
got to make tomorrow he goes what kind
of car I go it's a Lexus he goes who
[__] told you buy Lexus
dummy like [__] no no
sympathy and uh so that that that's what
happened then then I didn't get another
special till 2003 wow so from 97 to 2003
I had all this time to grow work on
material and I started seeing the world
and I started writing from a different
place and I started really polishing
this this act up and uh and that's the
one that blew me up and and so what was
it it you want you to pet
her there you go um and what was it
about this act that blew that blew you
up do you think that made it super
popular well this is the one that you
saw I I don't I don't know what it was I
it has to be a combination of timing for
sure because that's when file sharing
was started was popular MH so it was
timing and it was I had a lot of time to
work on that act so the act I knew was
solid and
um and and I just I didn't even think
about it when I did it I wasn't thinking
about oh this is going to be it you guys
are going to see I shot it they paid me
$7,500 for this one this is the same
company that paid me 10 grand six years
prior now they're paying me $2,500 less
and I'm like wow I just got a pay cut
but I was so broke at the time I was
broke broke like I had no money I was in
debt and uh I was like I'll take it
whatever and you know and then I'm like
I'll figure out what I'll do with this
act I don't know I was like it's going
to come out nobody's going to pay
attention it's he'll be fine I'll still
do the same act so you weren't like oh
this is gold you know I'm this is going
to crush no clue no clue no clue and did
it change financially for you did that
moment give you a big reward financially
at that point or not
so we shot in August of 2003 200
February Valentine's Day 2004 at
airs and uh in Canada but that same day
that it aired I had gotten a gig in
Chicago at depal University they were
pay me 700 bucks and I was like that's a
lot of money and 11 or 12 people came to
the show and I was like oof like nobody
knew who I was yeah and uh I was like
damn but I I did my show because I'm
like being paid to do this and it was a
good show
and then a month later my dad died I'm
like damn I don't know if my dad even
got to see like that the special came
out or nothing because he was already in
hospital at that time and I was like Dad
and he was like whatever so then
February 2004 11 people in Chicago Cut
to like November or October or November
of 2004 I go back to Chicago I'm sold
out at this theater for three nights and
I'm I don't know what's going on we
start getting bookings now we start
getting bookings right after my dad dies
this place wants to book you San
Francisco wants to book you and they'll
pay you $1,500 I'm like what how am I
going like I and I didn't have paperwork
at the time I was here working legally
and everything and then uh this place
wants to this Festival wants you and I'm
like what what's going on okay cool cool
you know I'm 15 years in the game now
I'm like thinking all right well I guess
is what happens when you're in it for a
while you start to you start to get more
work and then I think uh uh J for Laughs
had a tour that we did in Singapore they
did a Canadian tour and people were
coming out out to see me and I was like
that's weird and we did a Singapore tour
and people coming out to see me and I
was like huh how do they know me out
here what's going on I've been to
Singapore many times I was thinking oh
they must have seen me when I played the
Marriott on Orchard uh Road in the
basement and they came back to see me
you know what I mean because I did have
good sets when I would go and do them um
oh that's nice the people came back to
see me I'm naive I'm not thinking like
I'm not thinking there's something
bigger that can happen in this business
cuz I just it wasn't the way the game
was played before for and um I started
making like 30 grand one month and I was
like how the [__] I made 30 grand this
month then I made 40 Grand I was like
wait this what something's going on but
I don't know what's going on and then
somebody's like gives me a CD uh like a
CDR with my act on it and they go hey
man can you sign this I go what is that
he goes it's your act I go how' you get
my act on there go I download how' you
download it line wire bear share it was
file sharing I was like what the [__]
and then people started breaking down oh
somebody emailed me a clip of you doing
a joke about Italian somebody emailed me
you doing a joke about Jamaican somebody
emailed me you your Chinese joke and I
was like what what's how did this like
and then I remember people would email
you a clip remember back then they'd be
like hey check this out it would take
you 15 hours to download a thre minute a
three minute clip and uh and YouTube
starts in
2005 in June of 2005 or may of
2005 and um we get a call from Jimmy
Miller now Jimmy Miller is Dennis
Miller's brother Jimmy Miller's a
manager he also manages Jim
Carrey and we got a call
saying uh hey I'm trying to find this
guy Russell Peters uh and at the time I
started getting courted by agencies and
I'm still like what's going on and uh
Jimmy Miller wants to sign me to a deal
because his son he goes what what
happened Sam why are you why are you
tired he goes I was up all night
watching this comedian on you YouTube he
goes what the hell's YouTube and he goes
it's this thing well he goes who's the
comedian he goes Russell Peters he's
really funny and he was like what if my
son he goes his son I think was 12 at
the time or 13 he goes if my son is like
into this at this age we're missing
something here when so Jimmy Miller Tom
Werner uh I don't remember Cary Werner
back in the day they produced Cosby Show
and all those things back in the day and
uh and er Eric gold who produced In
Living Color so they started a company
called uh Warner gold Miller and uh and
I was their first deal and we had a deal
at Warner Brothers and it was a sitcom
deal and it was good money and and it
never went anywhere but then I got
agencies and then I started once I got
the deal I had to move to LA in 2006 I
moved here January 1st 2006 right so
you're going 15 years you're broke as
hell
mhm did you ever think about quitting no
why not because I enjoyed it m and for
me it was never about the money ever it
was never ever about the money there was
no I understand it came from a
workingclass family like nobody in my
family had money it's not like we had to
Aspire to anybody else in the family
we're all we're all just making ends
meet so I was like if I can just make
the ends meat I'm good you know what I
mean I like if I can make you know I was
thinking if I can make, 1500 bucks a
week doing standup I'm good I'm like
that's over 60 $70,000 a year that's a
lot of money back then I'm like I'm
making a good living and doing something
you enjoy too and I doing something to
enjoy I'm like why would I want to go
and work you know eight hours and get
paid a 100 bucks or something when I
could work you know 45 minutes and and
make a 100 bucks you know makes complete
sense and what was it like coming
because you came to LA and obviously
that's a very very different scene there
was The Comedy Store but the ice house
as well but that's pretty much it isn't
there the Laugh Factory and the yeah and
the Improv and who were the guys around
at that time well when I moved out here
I didn't know anybody
I literally didn't know anybody I uh
like I knew a couple people I'd met him
around over the years but I knew New
York guys more than I knew the LA guys
and uh I just you know I I think I did a
the Laugh Factory in 2005 that's what
happened I did the Laugh Factory in
2005 uh I don't know how it got put
together some promoter guy was like hey
you want to do the Laugh Factory I'll
sell it out and he sold out two shows of
the Laugh Factory and laugh laugh was
who is the [__] guy it's sold out
it's packed and he funny and we like it
so I got in there right away so when I
moved to LA I had a a home to go to
which was the Laugh Factory and Jamie
was always kind to me and uh the people
like why don't you go do the store I go
oh I I don't know I did the store like
in the 90s so I was like so I go to the
store go to enter from the back and the
guy's like uh Comics
only and I'm like huh and Yoshi was in
goes this Russell Peters he just sold
out the idiot and then so he got me and
we got in and and uh like those types of
things happen all the time though I
remember in 2005
I did the Apollo in Harlem sold it out
for two
nights and then uh I went to go do the
comic strip and the lady put me on on
the open mic night and I'm 16 years in
the game already and I just sold out the
Apollo two nights two shows and uh so I
do my five minute set and you know my
style is to talk to the crowd whatever
so I get off and I go so and she goes
well I don't usually let my opener my
open micers talk to the audience I don't
really like
that if you call in maybe in a couple of
months I might put you back on and I'm
like huh I go okay thanks and I left
like are you [__]
idiot comedy has just got a beautiful
way of humbling you doesn't it
absolutely absolutely So speaking of not
humbling though you go from you know
you're making a decent money and
whatever to suddenly you're take yeah
but you make money you'd be broke you
make money you'd be broke literally make
ends meet and then You' you'd stretch to
try and continue your life and suddenly
you make making 30 grand 40 Grand a
month mhm what are you thinking how are
you feeling in this moment I'm feeling
like it's going to end tomorrow I'm like
this I had a great month it's probably
over I had another great month probably
over after that there's no way this can
in my brain it was like this is not you
can't sustain this type of living this
is not this is not what you were in this
to do you were just in this to tell
jokes and you're not you're not a star
my brain kept going you're not a star
kid I don't know what you're doing and I
was like I don't know what I'm doing
either but let's just let's let just
keep going and see what happens you know
uhhuh and when did you know like okay
like I'm good now you know I've made it
I I I still don't know that come on man
I mean I know look around man what are
you talking about no I mean I know that
I'm
successful but I I you know and I know
what I'm capable of doing and I know
what I'm good at but for a comic we want
to hear somebody else say it to you you
know what I mean it's like if I say it
I'm like I almost feel like if I say it
then I'm going to jinx myself like I'm
going to [__] my whole thing up by
saying it really now you feel that now
always I always felt like that I do it
as a joke with my family like we'll go
out to a restaurant and the server be
like oh my God I'm a big fan and soon as
the server walks away I
go did you guys see
that see how popular I am very very
famous but it's like the running joke in
the family yeah so so you not only don't
let it get to your head you you are
still a little bit somehow still kind of
like this could be over soon yeah always
really I think that's what keeps me
working hard you're a hard worker yes
you grind
well it's comedy is it really hard work
it's not really hard work we're not
[__] saving lives here or are we no
we're not you know you've worked with
some incredible comedians one of them is
George Carlin mhm what was that like
well so George was my idol like he was
my everything mine as well and when I
met him I met him in
'92 by accident it was in Toronto the
night the Blue Jays won the World Series
and everybody was driving up and down
Young Street partying I'm 22 years old
I'm a punk ass kid I'm walking down the
street my my friends are driving every
traffic is moving so slow I'm walking
faster than the cars are driving so
we're walking and I see this older guy
with gray hair and a ponytail and a
beard walking towards me and I elbow my
friend and as a joke I go hey this
[__] guy looks like George Carlin and
when he walks by to a smartass I go hey
George and he goes how you doing kid and
I was like wait what the
[__] and I was like and I ran after him
and I just graveled the whole way back
to his I walked him back to his hotel I
don't think he wanted me to but I did
and I was like do you want Indian food
my mom will
make I'm like I don't know what the [__]
to say and I'm
like and I'm like uh hey uh uh you know
maybe we work together one day goes you
never know kid you never know crazy
business and then in 200 uh
eight when did he
die he died 2008 right round about then
yeah I think it's so 10 months before he
died he was going to do sets at The
Comedy and Magic Club and they knew I
loved Carlin and they're like you know
Carlin's coming in this week and to run
his set do you want to do you want to
come down and see it I go oh could I be
on the show and he goes yeah actually
and I go awesome can I host we already
have a host I go [__] i' would love to
host because I just want to be able to
have the honor of introducing him they
go we'll make that happen for you so
they let me host and I introduced him
did you bump I just I just moved him
into a middle spot that's all we just
flip spot that's all whoever that guy is
he's watching this
snack yeah anyway so I do the intro and
my chin starts quivering because I think
I'm going to cry I'm telling the story
how I inter met him and stuff and then
shakes my hand he leans and goes you're
making me look bad kid but he was such a
nice man he was just so awesome why did
you like him why did you like his work
because my dad was an English major
so uh language was always a big deal in
our house and uh my dad would always
refer to me as an ignoramus cuz I I
would always speak improperly and um but
my dad loved Carlin too because of his
word play and I you know growing up and
I liked hip-hop and if you're a good
rapper you got good word play so it was
all I think it all tied in together you
know and I just loved fun ways of having
fun with words that he would teach you
how to swear without swearing you know
what I mean and you know the with the
with the two halfway dirty words and
words aren't dirty until they're put
together and you know like [__] and
sucker and you know [__] in the Bible
you go to a dentist that gives you a
sucker you know yeah he was he was
magnificent as a comedian and what was
it like watching him live CU that must
have been I was I was floating I
couldn't remember to be honest I don't
remember it because I was just so like I
just on stage with George Carlin you
know and and who are the comedians that
you look up to Russell that you well
from that era was Carlin Steve Martin
uh don reckles Bob new har uh Eddie
Murphy and everyone goes what about
prior I go I appreciate prior but it
didn't resonate with me that's
interesting it I liked him but it didn't
hit me the way it hit other people you
know Eddie hit me better it was for me
it was like and every was like well
there's no Eddie without rich I get that
but Eddie somehow had the thing that
rich didn't have that little that way of
selling it to you better you know
because with Eddie he could do the
accents he could do the out so
beautifully Yeah Eddie would take you to
different places yeah and you saw that
in Eddie's films I remember in Beverly
Hills Cop to when you know when I was
watching it as a kid when he was doing
the act when he was we had the little
parcel these s for my daughters Monique
and unique and he was doing and he was
pretending to sweat and it just had me
dying yeah it was so good at that and so
those were the guys that I I really
watched and admired and then you know
you came up and then dice came out I was
like holy [__] you could you could say
this on stage Andrew Dice CL I was like
this is awesome I can't believe you
could say this on stage because then
swearing was like a big deal then and
we're like wow and he like they wanted
to shut him down I was like guys's a
rebel I love it then Kennison and you
know you got all those other guys that
came around because it was a big thing
then because people don't know this and
a lot of comedians have talked about it
in fact Rogan's talked about it a lot
that you had to be clean that was a
thing if you that was the big thing in
the when you in the early 90s late ' 80s
oh you got to be clean if you want to
get on TV you got to be clean and I was
like clean I don't want to be clean
seems so dorky to be clean you hear the
guys that were clean I go they're not
funny though yeah I go yeah they're
clever I'm like I don't give a [__] I
want to be funny yeah you go be clever
write a book dummy I I'm want to go be
funny yeah and Kinison was just an
example of a comedian who was just
completely unhinged at times but just
incredibly funny yeah I remember I
brought home a Kennison record back then
you can go to the library and rent
records and they had comedy section and
I brought home a Kennison record and I
remember playing it my dad lost his [__]
get get that Bloody blasphemy out of my
house like what don't ever bring that in
I'm like what what's going on I didn't
understand what was happening when he
was doing the it's been 2,000 years he's
not [__] coming
[Laughter]
back we'll be back with Russell in a
minute but first we want to tell you
about our sponsor fume if you want to
break your bad habit you can forget
about having to go cult turkey there's
now a better way we're talking about
fume it's spelled Fu M and pronounced
fume which makes no sense anyway not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a dramatic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavored air device that
does just that you can trade breathing
in nasty chemicals for breathing in
Fresh Air instead of vapor fume uses
flavored Air instead of electronics fume
is completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors it's a habit you're free to
enjoy and makes replacing your bad habit
easy your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
which gives your finger something to do
which is helpful for de-stressing and
anxiety while breaking your bad habit
I'll be honest I wasn't sure what to
expect with fume but they're actually
more flavorful than I thought and it
actually feels fresh the feel of them is
nice it's well weighted perfectly
balanced and they're made from real wood
which feels nice and looks great too
fume has served over 150,000 customers
and has thousands of success stories
there's no reason that can't be you join
fume in accelerating Humanity's breakup
from destructive Habits by picking up
the journey pack today head to trif
nume.com and use code trig to save 10%
off when you get the journey pack today
that's try
f.com and use code trig t r g to save an
additional 10% off your order today give
it a go it might just help you kick that
bad habit back to the
interview so how has comedy changed
because that's a really interesting
perspective right nobody would bat an
eyelid at a comedian swearing nowadays
but they might bat an eyelid at him
talking about trans or whatever like the
world has really changed in the time
that you've been in the game well now
you you have to really
figure out you can't just you can't just
flippantly say things on stage you have
to calculate them a little bit better
where is the hole in this statement like
if I say this what are the
counterarguments that could come at you
for this so you have to word it in a way
where it it kind of Curves you know so
it splices out like this argument stops
right there because I said this and that
stops there because I said that so so
the punch line doesn't get
affected like sorry just to finish this
thing like just had Neil Brennan on and
he was saying he actually likes the fact
that it's kind of like you have to think
five steps ahead and you got all these
lasers you're trying to dodge because it
makes him better do you agree with that
do you feel that I don't it makes it
better but it makes you think more and
the more you the more you think the
better you get so yeah I guess it does
make you better yeah yeah and do you
never is there a part of you where
you're sometimes on stage that you worry
that if you go a particular way it could
mean that someone will clip you out of
context and you know cancellation
or i i i i cuz I also know my intent
when I'm up there so if you're going to
you know you're if you're going to try
and manipulate my intent to suit yours
it's not going to work it's you're
you're you're you're trying to use
aftermarket parts in your story right
now yeah it's a good way of looking at
it because I think there there's a lot
of comedians actually and we've had
comedians who are very you know very
smart very liberal whatever else and
they say that sometimes when they write
material they censor themselves yeah
because they're worried about a
metaphorical backlash that may be coming
I'm not too worried about it because
again I've been in it 34 years now and
um also the people that come out to see
me are coming to see what I do they're
not coming to see what somebody else is
going to do they're coming to see they
want to hear what I say they want to
hear my perspective that's what they're
paying their money for and uh I always
tell people if I change to appease the
people that are not buying my tickets
I'm going to lose the people that are
buying my tickets and those [__] faces
are not going to buy a tickets and I'm
going be standing there with my dick in
my hand or or somebody's dick or a trans
dick one
dick I might have to transition after
that but that's that is such an
interesting thing that you point out and
I actually think it's completely true
which is very often whatever the storm
is on social media it's not from the
people who watch your stuff it's not
from the people who buy your your
tickets or whatever but people do panda
to that people are afraid of that yeah
I'm I I it's Bob Bome for sure um but I
you got to stop yourself and reason with
yourself be like this is not what it is
you know I see kids now like that people
post clips of me from 2008 and I look at
the comments and there's people like
this is [__] up how can he say this
and I'm like this 15 years old dude you
realize you weren't even probably even
born or or you were two years old when
this came out like just get over
yourself pal and and they're like oh
yeah he's I saw somebody some somebody
did a whole article on accents and stuff
and they tagged me in it and they were
like and somebody said Russell Peters
set us back 200 years I'm like no you
[__] 200 years you [__]
I put you forward you piece of [__] I
took the hits for you I did the [__]
rooms I got threatened I got chased out
of bars I got booed I had to do all the
things so that these little [__]
could come in and not have to do what I
did it's did did that happen to you you
got chased out of bars and yeah it
happened here and there you know how
come did what whatever reason you're
doing a bar in a little small town a
bunch of [__] rednecks you know you
do the jokes and you're funny like a and
then get out you're done and I'm like oh
get out like oh [__] all right I'll
leave you get like you know just just
that's the world it was back then and
it's such a profound point that you make
in that you need those people to push
through the barriers you need to be the
first comedian you know from Asian
background in order so that other people
can look at it and go oh I want to do
that yeah there if you look at it now
there was back in the day um when I
started there was me and then when I
went to England there was Jeff
murza who I don't know I guess I was
just a egotistical arrogant little
[__] kid but I kept bumping heads
with him and I was like [__] that guy
but Jeff never was personal it was just
my ego don't trip um and then you had uh
goodness gracious me back then that was
brilliant that [__] made me go oh we can
be really funny and so there was like
this wave of us you know and I was and
there was no real stand-ups out of
England so I was the guy who came in
from Canada and and I was still Indian
so they were like oh what is this this
is interesting why does he talk like
that and I'm like why do you talk like
that and so we had this whole little
thing and I remember I did warmup for
Real McCoy one time when I was out there
yeah um but yeah when you're the first
one people are always nervous you know
I'm pretty sure goodness gracious me got
some backlash back then because they
were afraid but if you look at it now
that [__] is so funny still yeah it
holds up you know and this I there's
nothing that frustrates me more than
when people look at a clip from 15 20
years ago and judge it in how you would
judge something from 2023 it's so
ridiculous yeah you can't you can't
again and they they want to erase the H
history you cannot erase the past you
need that there so you don't make the
same mistakes twice because if you don't
if you have no point of reference you're
going to you're going to completely [__]
your [__] up again and then also there's
this whole taking things out of context
and presenting them and what they tried
to do to Rogan with the whole nword
thing what did you make of that yeah
that was some serious [__] and they
tried to peg him as a racist and I I
know him very very well I mean we've
known each other for a long time and
we've rolled we've we' fought each other
we've rolled in Jiu-Jitsu together we've
we've hung out we've I I've been to his
house I know his wife I know his kids I
know everything and and I was like I was
I posted on my page I go this is not the
guy you're trying to paint him out to be
I then I remember I got calls from
people DL hugley called me I was like yo
Russell let me tell you something I go
darl Daryl cuz I know all these I'm
Daryl I'm telling you if he was a racist
I would say I'd be the first one to tell
you guy's a [__] racist but he's not
stop trying to paint him like that stop
don't fall for the okey
do I I defended him to my close friends
I had to defend him to and I was like
it's not the guy you're trying they're
trying to sell you him what they're
trying to do is they're trying to take
away his uh Spotify money is what
they're trying to do you know why do you
think people do that that do you have
any thoughts on that why why people want
to like tear down people make them look
bad like it doesn't make sense to me I
don't get it either because I don't do
it so I'm always like I mean if the
person's a real piece of [__] [__]
yeah but when they try to do it to
people who you know are not bad people
that's when I get you know I get
defensive I'm like that no I'm not going
to let you do it to this person because
they're not bad people and the thing
that I hate as well is that you're
destroying the art form as well yeah
you're making the wrong eyes look at it
now oh that's interesting tell us more
well you got the you know you got people
who aren't paying attention to Comedy
and don't care about it now they've
heard some sort of Rumblings about it
now they look over and they're seeing
the thing that is not going to appeal to
them and then they go that's why we
didn't like it look it's trash and then
they get on their high horse about it
and and so it just adds fuel to their
fire that's such a good point I think
that and the more people different
people from different walks of life we
meet the more we kind of realize that
there's some people that just don't get
or like comedy yeah and those are the
people who are outraged about every
[__] thing that happens that get
shoved in front of their face by a
journalist yeah it's the same thing with
me for like young rap music I I can't
stand it I grew up I'm a big hip-hop
head and people like why do you hate the
young the new music so much and and I I
stopped myself and I went they're not
making it for me so why do I care if
it's not being made for me why should I
give a [__] if it's good or bad and it's
the old guy syndrome at that point
you're like back in our day we had you
know and we did but that was for us it
was made for us who's catered to us and
that's who it's for and we I I think
what we're trying to do is say hey kids
if you dig deeper there's more to this
than you're
seeing but we're not articulating that
well it's it's a really profound Point
Russell because it it's so easy now in
the age of the internet to see a clip to
have an immediate reaction where you
don't don't actually think about
anything it's just an emotional reaction
and then you give an emotional response
and then you create this entire Twitter
stum or whatever it is yeah and before
you know it it's out of control yeah you
make one comment uh you know you can't
that's the thing now as as far as as I'm
getting older I know I wait before I
respond to certain things because I'm
like I don't want to just give my
knee-jerk reaction cuz that's probably
the not the right reaction you you want
to give a more thought out well-rounded
response you know I find it interesting
with comedians where they respond to I
don't know if you've seen this guy Matt
R so let me tell you about Matt
R about five years ago Matt R used to
open for me I took on the road for me a
bunch of dates and he's a great kid he's
a really good-looking kid he's a very
funny kid and he's a he's he's got all
the
ingredients and he hit me up and he was
like hey bro I'm having trouble getting
an agent do you think you I go let me
call my agency let me put a word in for
you so I call my agency I say you guys
you thought about Matt r no I go what do
you mean do you know him yeah we're
familiar I go the kid's a home run he's
really good-looking really funny he's
young he's he's he's a he's a great kid
he's not a [__] I go he's got all
the I'm telling you the kid is a star
and whoever takes him is going to make a
lot of money the kid is is a star and
they're like no we're going toay ass and
now look at Matt R and my agent every
time I see my agent I go hey remember
when I offered you Matt R he goes I know
I
know next time you offer me somebody I'm
taking them cuz I offered him Theo Von
as well at that time wow I said Matt r
with Theo Von they were like n we're
passing and I'm like you're [__]
idiots who how do you run this business
when you don't know when you can't spot
the talent Theo is one of our favorite
episodes we interviewed him when we were
here in in the US last year right and
he's blown up thanks to us no it's your
fault no but he's really blown up as
well I mean what were you going to say
about my wife no because I was just
saying that I you know I sit in green
rooms and then you get comedians going
look at my wife look at and you know and
they just hate by Nature I
mean you know listen the kid the kid was
destined for this look at him got
[__] six-pack and he's he's in he
looks better than ever I I whenever he'd
open for me he'd come out and go give it
over for Matt he's my favorite lesbian
comic and that's such a profound point
and I say to these comedians I go look
it ain't for you yeah it ain't for you
yeah you know he's got a whole audience
I don't like Taylor Swift but apparently
I'm wrong I don't see anything about
Taylor Swift that is appealing looks
music show nothing nothing about her
appeals to me but obviously I'm wrong
because there's a [__] billion people
that love her yeah so just cuz I don't
like something doesn't mean it's not
likable or right and there's a
narcissism about that it's like well if
I don't like it then [__] no maybe you
just don't like stuff and other people
like it what's so complex about that
yeah people people have a have a tough
time taking themselves out of the
equation yeah that's a good point and
it's also interesting what you said
about the agents not spotting Matt R not
spotting Theo and it does seem to be a
thing where you there's so many talented
people and you just go how come this
person it's obvious all yeah there's
there's and then you see people who they
just keep forcing in front of you and
you're like I don't know nobody it's
just not catching cuz you're like you're
trying to force Fe to something we don't
want right and I think that's uh not to
bring it back to me but I think I I
think that's
the I think that's the beauty of my
career is that I was
never um created yes by the industry I
mine was all organically grown and my
fan base stays loyal and solid and I
stay loyal and solid to them because I I
refuse to lose them I refuse to give
them a reason to to not be with me and
um so I bust my ass to keep them and
they they bust their ass to stay there
with me so it's a respecting and the
industry doesn't like when you can do
something like that because they can't
take it away from you so if you notice I
never really blew up in the industry per
se I never did A-list movies and I did a
couple you know but it was like because
I knew the director or whatever whatever
reason I got in I got in um but I don't
get invited to certain things and I
don't get included and it used to bother
me but honestly now I'm like I don't
give a [__] anymore I'm 53 years old I
don't give a [__] about your shitty
award show I'm going to be bored there
anyway that's such a powerful place to
be like that's what I was going to say
about the power of the internet now you
don't need Gatekeepers you don't have to
care about them like we build this by
ourselves and it's such a great place to
be because you don't have to do anything
anyone's way you just got to do what you
believe in and feed your audience the
stuff that they're interested in and
that's it you're just doing you're doing
you yeah and there's only one you or two
in this
case no it's amazing that that you've
got that and um it's interesting you
were talking about you kind of blew up
by yourself I was going to ask you do
you think you were lucky in any way 100%
really I 100% believe I'm lucky in what
way it's it's a question of time uh
timing and place all at the right it
just connected at that time 2003 when we
shot it and it aired 2004 who was going
to know that a year later YouTube was
going to start and that what was just
audio in
2004 and the beginning of 2004 became
video by the end of 2004 in pieces and
then by 2005 the entire the entire
special shows up on this channel and you
can watch the whole thing that you've
been listening to for all for the past
year and a half and you go wow that's
the guy that's amazing now we know what
to look for now I know who it is and
then they connect with you and you know
it's 20 years now since I shot that
special and I get a lot of kids now in
their 40s that are like man you helped
me through college and I'm like wow cuz
I don't think of myself as that old I
mean but I am I guess you know I'm like
I was 33 when I shot that special 32 33
and so you know I guess yeah I did help
you get through college but I wasn't
trying to and then you think about the
things that you connected with when you
were younger like I'm friends with a lot
of uh like everybody I had a poster of
in my wall when I was a kid I'm friends
with them now so you know Big Daddy Kane
uh L Cool J uh um Lord finesse lives
here with us um he's one of my favorite
rappers growing up and and now he's one
of my his family at this point so I'm in
a different place now so when I even you
become friends with the people you
forget that they're that person now cuz
you look at them like that like I'm a
fan of Constantine's you too
Francis but uh you like watching me
destroy people I love watching
Constantine destroy people it's always
my favorite thing why are you interested
in that Russell because I envy that
ability in that skill I lack it fine but
the subject matter the subject matter
because I you articulate it well and
when things are articulated well there's
no you can't argue it it's like he
[__] had his Point ready loaded
thought out it wasn't it wasn't a just
an off-the-cuff answer these are like
this is all filled with information and
points that that that you weren't
prepared to when you came at him so
you're jealous of me is what you're
saying I'm very
jealous matter of fact listen talk about
cross country
skin no I'm just curious because you're
are very affable you're very likable
you're very chill I can see there's no
Edge to you you're not sitting going
[__] trans women aren't women or
whatever that that's not you right at
all and yet you're interested in the
stuff some of the stuff that we we get
we talk about in modern
society yeah because it's it's always
being like when I'm trying to like
explain it to people well here's why and
they're like well why well that's just
because you say that I go no but here I
I'm trying to be reasonable with you and
you're still trying to be [__]
unreasonable and I get frustrated by
that that type of behavior you know when
you're trying to when you're trying to
bend and they're not well they're
bending but I
mean's got a Bend I
mean so it's kind of sorry do you feel a
little bit annoyed that people are
imposing their world view on other
people is I yes that's what it is like
listen I got my own problems in my own
life I got all my whatever I'm dealing
with that's not your problem that's my
problem whatever is bothering me or is
inside of me that I'm dealing with
should not be your problem unless you
ask me and you're like hey share
something with me something B you know
then yeah but I'm not going to be like
yeah well you think you you got it bad
I'm blah blah it's it's such a it is a
very narcissistic World we're living in
and it's becoming more and more
narcissistic and narcissists are the
worst [__] humans on the planet and
that's a man who's been around a lot of
comedians yes and and narcissists what's
the difference uh I had a kid with
[Laughter]
some oh man it's it's been such a great
interview Russell Russell has been a
pleasure man was good I
mean it was great I I was go for I was
going to say before we go to uh locals
where we ask questions from our
supporters last question we always ask
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be um this this going to
be controversial no it's not no um no by
us
people keep talking about Palestine and
Israel MH okay this might
be and they always approach it from
Jewish and
Muslim but here's something that I was
privy to hear when I was in the Arab
world and from some people in that
situation and I said what is the problem
there is it Jewish Muslim is it Israeli
is a Palestinian he said no they said
it's a white nonwhite
issue the Israelis identify as white
whether they limited or not and the
Palestinians are not white that's really
what it is and that's why it gets the
support from everybody else even though
they look very similar they look similar
but
there's not similar enough there's a hue
there's a slight Hue difference now the
Israelis are not it's the it's the
external factors that come in that are
the white ones you know the Israelis are
more akin to the Palestinians but when
you got all the Europeans coming in
they're [__]
Europeans like they're not looking at
these people the same way they might
even look at the Israelis a different
way you know what I mean like that's
it's it's it's a real
thing there you go mildly controversial
all right head on over to locals we'll
ask some of your questions as well see
you there can't wait for the death
threats on that
one still one of my favorite bits of
Comedy his impression of his dad is
hilarious somebody going to get hurt
real bad somebody somebody going to get
a hurt real bad you know the true story
behind that
[Music]
is